the joe rogan experience barry knuckle
boxing legend
big joe joyce dipped hands in petrol
ahead of bruce
brutal fights oh is this that irish guy
one of those gentlemen
hard as stone as what he said made me
hands harder stone rock hard
oh let me hear this fella caught can we
hear him talk oh yeah
he's a this is a traveler why is it
why isn't it okay to say gypsy anymore
what happened i don't know
is that not acceptable anymore that's
what i heard what do you think is
bandages
because brands just kills a couch and i
hear the culture man then i'll do
nothing
okay just stop right there because we
don't understand what he's saying i
i would refer to him as i wouldn't refer
to him as a gypsy i would refer to him
as a [ __ ] that's a oh [ __ ]
yeah um well they call themselves
travelers as well
right it's so it's these are weird
distinctions you know yeah that's how
probably offended a bunch of people
there which i'm i didn't mean to do but
yeah absolutely bunch of tough
[ __ ] yeah for sure yeah bunch
of really tough [ __ ] it's nikki
holtzkin isn't he uh
is that from that that's not sure i
think he is
he's very pretty tyson fury for sure
tyson furious
i used to train the same boxing gym as
him like he used to have the ring
the hour before me and i remember
watching him he was just like this big
hulking monster walking around dude he's
so improved ridiculously tall
ridiculous he's so tall and long and he
moves so good for a big heavyweight
nice dude god damn he's a great guy he's
a sweetheart of a guy
and he really genuinely cares to reach
out to people and tell them that if you
are going through depression
if you're dealing with and suffering
from mental illness talk about it and
get help
because i almost killed myself and now
here i am champ of the world feeling
great yeah
i'd love to see him against andy ruiz i
would love to see that too
i think we'll see that i think we'll see
all these fights andy ruiz is uh
not looking forward to fighting in saudi
arabia apparently yeah why is it there
i do not look again one more time i'm a
[ __ ] i'm not a fight promoter i don't
know what the [ __ ] goes on behind the
scenes with lawyers and i don't know
what what the contract said that he had
but what i had heard was that he had to
fight in england like that was in the
contract that's what i had heard
but that could be horse [ __ ] yeah i mean
i have no idea maybe maybe it says in
the contract that they have the right to
tell them i shouldn't even said that i
heard that because i don't remember who
told to me
but the point is there's a story that
just came out that he does not want
this fight to be in saudi arabia and i
think he wants a fight in new york again
he he said he doesn't trust it over
there you know like he he doesn't trust
it in england either he doesn't trust
fighting joshua in england he's like no
no no no no no no i get it i mean he's
the champ now he can call his shot
he's called the champion yeah he's the
champ man super nice guy have you met
him
no no i have not met him he's great he
was awesome on your podcast he's great
it's a good dude man genuine as [ __ ] and
boy does he have
like fluidity and efficiency in his
punches no wasted movement yes
yeah and the other thing i was i was
talking to um tim hendricks about
we were discussing boxing he's he
actually trains at the rooker gym with
um
uh jason pirillo he's had a couple of a
couple of fights
my huge jason prolo fan yeah he's very
very very good coach man
very good in the corners he's great like
his advice is great and you see like the
advancement of his pupils he's got that
deep bass voice
and he doesn't toot his you know that
guy just stays under the radar
and just kicks ass